on va maintenant rejoindre stéphane
bancel qui est pdg du laboratoire
américain moderna therapeutics
l'entreprise de biotechnologie qui a
lancé le premier essai de vaccin contre
la coved 19 et qu'il y ait de publier
d'ailleurs des résultats fort
encourageants monsieur bancel bonjour
bonjour alors monsieur van ciel tout
d'abord et expliquez nous est-ce que
vous en êtes rendu parce que vous avez
reçu beaucoup d'argent du gouvernement
américain vous avez commencé à faire des
tests sur des êtres humains alors c'est
encourageant tout ça ça va bien oui
alors je dirais c'est encourageant c'est
bien sûr encore tôt mais c'est la
première fois qu'on est capable de
donner des résultats sur les premières
personnes qui ont reçu les vaccins
donc le vaccin à démarrer les études
cliniques de phase 1 à seattle le 16
mars
ça a été réalisée par les laboratoires
de du nhs le national
et si tu te fais à l'oeuf américain du
docteur tony facci et dans ce qu'ont
annoncé lundi sur le site résultat c'est
que d'abord au niveau de la sécurité et
de la tolérabilité le vaccin est bien
toléré
ce qui est bien sûr très important parce
que la sécurité est la priorité numéro
un en vaccins mais ce qui est très
encourageant bien que ce soit encore tôt
et sur les premières personnes dont on
est les resultats le matin des résultats
supplémentaires dans les semaines qui
arrivent ont montré qu'ils font des
anticorps après vaccination qui
neutralise le virus donc ça c'est un
point important d'optimisme c'est qu'ils
somment que le vaccin soit bien toléré
et semble faire les bons anticorps qui
protègeraient et on a aussi annoncé
lundi que dans les animaux que nous
avons fait les tests comme on fait
chaque fois bien sûr pour les
médicaments
on a en fait montré que si on vaccine
des animaux et que ce même vaccin et
qu'ensuite on donne des du virus à ses
animaux pour cela comme une infection si
vous voulez en fait que tous les animaux
étaient protégés donc c'est à dire
qu'une fois qu'ils ont eu le vaccin ils
ne peuvent pas leur ai attrapé c'est ça
la série frisant le vaccin si on donne
le virus pour essayer de faire comme si
c'était si vous voulez une simulation
d'une infection naturel que pour avoir
un être humain
après sa vaccination mais en fait tous
les animaux
on était protéger de l'infection bon
vous travaillez actuellement avec 45
volontaire je crois ce sont tous des
gens qui ont eu le virus qui ont été
atteints par l'aco vide alors c'est sûr
des gens qui sont sains cd succédé des
êtres humains qui sont sains qui ont été
testées avant d'être admis en essai
clinique pour s'assurer d'abord qu'ils
sont en bonne santé et pour s'assurer
qu'ils n'ont pas les anticorps du virus
c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont pas été
infectés avant par le virus alors quand
on développe un vaccin comme ça si vous
êtes vous devez avoir un a remis deux
chercheurs qui travaillent pour vous
actuellement
on commence par quoi alors nous avons
effectivement bientôt 1000
collaborateurs dans la société et
beaucoup de partenaires externes comme
donc le machin et six trophées unfp qui
nous a aidé pour l'essai clinique
il ya aussi bien sûr beaucoup de
fournisseurs et c'est donc ce qui avait
trait à une autre technologie c'est que
c'est le dixième vaccins en fait
différence pour un virus différents que
nous faisons en essais cliniques
nous avons maintenant d'oser plus de
2000 personnes à travers le monde sur
notre technologie réside une technologie
très innovante savane une technologie de
biologie moléculaire
ça s'appelle la molécule de les rênes
message et c'est en fait la molécule
dans toutes vos cellules de votre corps
qui se situe entre votre adn et vos
protéines leur en fait c'est
l'instruction qui est utilisée par votre
corps pour faire vos protéines vous même
comme par exemple l'insuline l'hormone
de croissance toutes les protéines dans
votre corps et dans ce cas là ce qu'on a
fait c'est qu'on a pris l'instruction
génétique du virus
lorsque les autorités chinoises l'ont
publié sur internet le 11 janvier on a
poussé instructions génétiques du virus
on a choisi une protéine du virus que
nous considérions avec les membres donc
du nageur et si je t'offre américain
comme étant la plus importante pour la
vaccination et nous avons donc design et
le vaccin sur ordinateur et ensuite nous
avons commencé la production directe des
laudes essais cliniques en parallèle de
la déteste fondamentale bien sûr sur les
animaux et il faut que le produit était
bien confirmé comme étant
bien fait par rapport aux spécifications
de fabrication nous l'avons envoyé aux
nachi des fèves qui donc le 16 mars à
démarrer la phase 1 ensuite le prochaine
grosse étape c'est bien sûr la phase 2
qui sera dans quelques jours démarré sur
600 personnes on augmente le nombre de
personnes doucement encore une fois
monsieur de la sécurité des gens et on a
annoncé lundi aussi que la phase iii la
dernière phase de tests en essais
cliniques devraient démarrer au mois de
juillet donc très bientôt
on n'a pas encore annoncé la taille
parce qu'on est en train de finaliser
avec la f10 américaine la taille de
cette étude
mais ce sera plusieurs milliers de
personnes on communiquera bien sûr très
rapidement la taille de ces études des
claviers de la confirme mais là vous
êtes conscient qu'un en parlant de
téléspectateurs comme ça monsieur bassin
vous donner énormément d'espoir aux gens
c'est très encourageant et ça va très
vite aussi vous êtes surpris par le
rythme auquel ça va alors savait
effectivement très vite pour vous donner
une comparaison
lorsqu'il ya eu une infection du south
qui je me souviens avait aussi touché le
canada il ya de nombreuses années il ait
fallu vingt mois entre la disponibilité
de la séquence génétique du virus et le
démarrage du premier essai clinique
donc là on a mis 63 jours donc deux mois
donc on allait pratiquement dix fois
plus vite et c'est vraiment lié à la
technologie de moderna qui est très très
nouvelle je pense qu'il ya des fortes
chances que le vaccin soit utilisé parce
que si une personne deux par exemple au
canada étaient protégés le taux de
transmission du virus diminuerait de
manière très importante et ça c'est
vraiment important quand vous avez sans
doute entendu parler au développement
développent une immunité il exactement
si vous aviez 50% des gens plus tous les
gens qui ont déjà été infectées au
canada naturellement vous aurez fait une
immunité de la société canadienne qui
permettrait un retour à la vie le temps
file monsieur mancel cécile fascinant ce
que vous nous racontez et ça va
tellement vite et ça donne beaucoup
d'espoir alors ce vaccin si jamais vous
arriver à des conclusions positives au
mois de septembre par exemple ou un peu
plus tard on ne sait pas est-ce qu'il
sera accessible à tout le monde parce
que vous recevez beaucoup vous avez
absolue quoi 2
milliards de la part du gouvernement
américain ainsi que monsieur thiam le
favoriser les américains avant que tout
le monde alors est ce que au niveau de
la propriété intellectuelle ce vaccin
sera disponible en europe en amérique du
nord en asie partout oui donc
effectivement j'ai la chance d'avoir
passé beaucoup de ma carrière dans le
laboratoire eli lilly qui est une grosse
société internationale et donc dès qu'on
a commencé à travailler sur ce vaccin
je me suis posé la question avec mon
équipe de comment on s'assure d'avoir
beaucoup de doses lusine que nous avons
dans le massachusetts ne permet que de
faire 100 millions de doses par an ce
qui est déjà un nombre énorme de vaccins
mais bien sûr pas suffisant pour la
planète et donc ce que nous avons fait
ce que nous avons annoncé un accord avec
la société suisse qui s'appelle lonza
qui est un des plus grands phares aux
quatorze fabricants par don de
médicaments dans le monde qui nous
permet de monter jusqu'à 1 milliard de
doses par an bien sûr ça va prendre
plusieurs milliers arriver c'est un
milliard comment vous assurez monsieur
mancelle parce que c'est très politique
tout ça que vous ayez encore une
certaine indépendance après avoir reçu
tout cet argent des gouvernements
comment vous êtes sûrs et que vous
demeurez autonome et que vous mais comme
société vous pouvez prendre vous même
vos décisions sans est à la solde des
américains ou des européens ou des
canadiens euros oui effectivement c'est
en créant beaucoup de capacités
production est effectivement le problème
politique se passe essentiellement quand
il n'y a pas assez parce que tout le
monde veut et tous les hommes politiques
du monde entier ont bien sûr la
responsabilité de protéger leurs leur
pays
c'est normal c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
et lui c'est l'or c'est leur devoir et
donc nous notre solution à ça c'est de
fournir de grandes quantités de vaccins
et de collaborer avec les états pour
s'assurer que ce n'est pas un état qui
prennent de tous les vaccins pour que
toute sa population soit vaccinée
mais quand se focalise sur les gens à
risque les personnes âgées
le corps médical et c'est vraiment les
priorités que chaque pays doivent avoir
d'abord avant de faire les gens plus
jeunes qui sont en bonne santé
bon on est très conscient qu'elle
faisait dans une lutte dans une
bataille dans une course effrénée pour
trouver ce vaccin vous n'êtes pas le
seul il ya des centaines de chercheurs
et de centres de recherche et de
compagnies pharmaceutiques qui font la
même chose que vous pourquoi votre
vaccin est meilleur que les autres ou
votre recherche est plus avancée que les
autres actuellement
alors effectivement je ne peux pas dire
scientifiquement que notre action est
meilleur que les autres parce que vous
pouvez dire ça quand je dois été comparé
ce qui n'a pas été le cas
une des raisons qu'on est allé très vite
et qu'on a été le premier produit à
démarrer des études cliniques dans le
monde
je veux dire essayer plusieurs choses
vraiment notre technologie dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure et une technologie
basée sur l'information génétique et
donc ça va bien aller beaucoup plus vite
nous avons à ce jour laboratoire de
modern est toujours pas eu accès au
virus physiquement c'est ça qui est
vraiment intéressant par rapport à la
vieille technologie de développer des
vaccins seconde mans c'était pas notre
premier vaccin
comme je vous ai 19 vaccin avant on fait
des essais cliniques
donc on avait beaucoup plus vite et nous
avons notre propre idée de production
dans les normes de vaccins que vous
mentionnez il est en fait beaucoup de
laboratoires académiques qui ont de la
très bonne science je suis sur les gens
qui travaillent très dur mais s'ils
n'ont pas encore l'expérience
industrielle de pouvoir faire des
produits pharmaceutiques qui ont une
réglementation très stricte
comme c'est important pour protéger les
gens qui sont injectés par le vaccin
en fait ça sera des temps très long pour
que ces vaccins la cie et marche
scientifiquement puisse démarrer des
essais cliniques mais monsieur bancel on
était suspendu à vos lèvres je pense que
c'est absolument incroyable d'être
rendue aussi loin aussi rapidement on
verra bien si toute cette recherche
toute cette technologie servira un jour
et se concrétisera et que vous aurez
effectivement les moyens d'en produire
des milliards de doses
c'est ce que la planète actuellement
espèrent et souhaitent merci infiniment
stéphane bancel pdg de la compagnie
moderna de nous avoir accordé cette
entrevue et bon courage
bon courage merci merci